Lee what trends have you seen in the
screenwriting business in The Last 5
Years well it really depends on TV
versus film right because in film we
really had a period of going away from
original content um going more towards
IP so we see the studios going more
towards IP based screenplays um however
this last summer has been a huge game
changer because this summer while it was
on par with previous Summers so far as
box office is concerned it was mostly
Indies that really were able to prop up
the summer box office it had not been
for Indie successes like bad mom and
some horror films that came in and
changed the landscape we would have been
behind about 25% in our annual box
office so that's changing the landscape
again so far as what people are looking
for in content we also saw the bubble
burst um as far as the superhero movies
and so we are veering again more towards
original content that's where scripts
like bubbles by Isaac Adamson that was
on top of of The Blacklist at the end of
2015 really gets to shine because it's
such an original unique story story of
Michael Jackson's chimp um and so we are
seeing the search for truly original
work again in on the film space on the
TV space we're moving away from
procedural which was really the
broadcast network cashow now that we are
at about 450 programs scripted programs
per year in the original space we're
seeing a lot more growth in the pay
cable and the basic cable and in the
digital streamer space those lean on
serialized narratives a lot more so than
procedurals so we're seeing that skew as
well as well as half-hour comedy
becoming less funny haha and a lot more
interesting relationship comedy things
like casual transparent which is really
a a drama um so we're seeing a lot more
exploration of the half hour space in a
less traditional networking kind of
manner and do you think that it's all
all cyclical and that at some point
we'll revert back to sort of these as
you said Network sort of Blockbusters I
don't know that we will ultimately if
we're looking at television we are in
the time of peak TV Peak TV was expected
to max out at about 450 shows we're now
anticipating that this peak will last
through
2019 um and we'll get up to 550 plus now
even in that case networks will will be
responsible for about 150 of those shows
so there's only so many pro procedurals
that will be be made the bulk of the
growth that we're seeing is on the basic
cable front on the pay cable uh front
and on the digital front and those are
really finding their footing with
serialized dramas with more
exploratory content um as far as Studios
what we've seen happen in studios as far
as the Blockbuster goes the summer
blockbuster the superhero movie this is
something that has been in the works
since the mid 90s when most Studios were
purchased by corporations that put in
some brand strategy to develop these big
Brands and to really build up to box
office success that has now evaporated
what's the next step for the studios
that's for all of us to find out but
certainly has changed and it will
continue to change what it'll change too
is the big question what are some of
your favorite episodes that you've seen
come out in terms of the serialized
content oh gosh there's so much good
serialized content out there um I'm a
child of the 80s so stranger things to
me was is so wonderful um I'm a big fan
of everything from the affair to Broad
Church which is a British series Rectify
on Sundance that's about to be done kind
of heartbreaking um you know I think
Breaking Bad is the greatest thing ever
created for television Sons of Anarchy
um the list just goes on and on and on I
also love documentary Series so the Jinx
making a murderer I think there's a lot
to be learned from those um but there's
just so much good content right now I'm
catching up on the crown which is really
fantastic um I I don't have enough time
to view everything that I want and need
to view because I have a lot of writers
on a lot of these shows um but that's
kind of the pleasure of our time right
that uh you get sick you lie in bed for
a day you can start catching up on
something you've been wanting to see and
it's going to be a highly satisfying and
very unique experience um you know shows
like the night of Westworld everybody
loves Netflix and HBO these days they're
doing great great stuff and it's really
inventive and developing you know we're
we're Chang in year after year we're
seeing new contents we're seeing new
Explorations we're not rehashing things
right now which is just so exciting
right and really pushing the envelope oh
yeah you know you talk about being a
child of the 80s as I am as well and and
just nothing was sort of pushed that far
in terms of some of the content and
subject matter and absolutely and I and
I think that Netflix specifically
Netflix Amazon um as well as FX and some
of those smaller homes that a tours have
found really allowed creators to create
12 episodes to tell their story so
creators really went out and told their
story with that much more confidence in
the through line as opposed to just
trying to sell a pilot which is the
experience on network you try to sell a
pilot you try to put it into development
you try to have the pilot shot you try
to have the pilot picked up but you
don't really get that through line of 12
episodes right off the bat um so we're
really seeing aurs hit their stride and
really take you on a journey that
they're not t tentative on in any way
shape or form and that's really exciting
it seems like to the flawed character as
the hero now more so than ever or maybe
I'm wrong we we certainly are seeing
that and I think there's a move away
from the likable hero to the relatable
hero um we like I said earlier Breaking
Bad is my favorite thing ever so I find
myself talking about it a lot Walter
White wasn't necessarily likable but he
was highly relatable a lot of people in
this world feel that they've settled and
it was his quest to be the best version
of himself even if that version is
Heisenberg that really rallied an
audience around him so we are no longer
in this place of you have to be Mary
Poppins right you have to be beloved and
darling and Flawless but rather
relatable and I think the
relatability um is what's drawing
audiences and where different people are
finding different homes um you know this
this lack of perfection has been
refreshing to say the least for a long
time we were in a place in TV and what
we call dark and getting darker um I
think that we've moved away from that a
little bit um shows like Penny Dreadful
that was a great show was one of the
height of those like how much darker can
we go here we saw that happening and
still see it happening in Walking Dead
that's still on the air and then fear of
The Walking Dead but I think that we are
now moving back into more of a
serialized storytelling as opposed to an
exploration of of the depth of
Darkness does the screenwriter really
have to live in Los Angeles it depends
if the screenwriter wants to write for
television the answer as much as people
hate to hear it is yes television is a
all Hands-On deck kind of business so
you really do have to be here for a
writer to get staffed for a writer to
sell a pilot there's going to be an
obscene amount of meetings that precede
that there's an obscene amount of
networking so a writer really does need
to be here for television unless they
are brought in by their agent their
manager just to sell a pilot um and
they're able to come in for weeks at a
time for meetings that said if you want
a staff on television you have to be
here people are not going to take a
chance that you'll make the move once
you get the job and they're going to
give more consideration to writers who
are available to walk into the room in
two days I can tell you most of my
writers who've gotten staffed um for the
first time on a show usually got the
word five or six days before um it's not
one of those things that you know weeks
and weeks and months in advance you hope
you have suspicions you're told by the
showrunner but you don't have your
paperwork in hand until a few days
before the room opens um and so you have
to be available to not only be in the
room when the room opens but also
Network Executives want to meet with you
it wasn't expected but here they are
it's now 10:00 on a Wednesday morning
and they want you in at 3 and if you
can't make it you don't have the job so
you have to be available for all of
those things I find that showrunners and
executive producers are less willing to
take a chance on writers that they don't
know to be available in that fashion now
for film writers I find the situation
very different as a film writer you can
be anywhere in the country the world is
a little bit more difficult because we
do want you to be available for meetings
be available quickly um so I do find
that a lot of people are a bit more
forgiving as far as geography is
concerned for feature writers the most
important thing about living in Los
Angeles is that it's a sign of your
commitment to this career
um I work with a great feature writer
who lives in Colorado who met a manager
who wanted to sign him and the manager
knew that we had worked together and so
he called me and he said how do I know
this guy's really serious he's in
Colorado and so I had to step in and say
no no no I promise I swear I've read
more than one piece this writer this is
the career this is what he's doing it's
not a hobby um so the move to Los
Angeles is not so much for availability
on the film site even though that is
important so I don't want to discount
that you have opportunities to network
and meet and not only meet Executives
but meet your class of writers but it is
an important sign of commitment to this
is the thing that I want it is not a
hobby it is not a thing that might or
might not turn out to be um it's
something that I'm banking on um you
know a lot of people talk about coming
to Los Angeles because this is where
movies and television are made and if
this is what you want to be a part of if
you can you should get here now as a
mother of Two and a wife life I
certainly understand that if my life was
elsewhere and I wanted to be a writer
maybe moving is not that available to me
um if that is indeed the scenario then
the writing has to be that much stronger
so that it does get noticed through the
shorer channels of the big big contest
so if you're a feature writer you want
to get to semi-finalist in the nickel
Fellowship not necessarily just the
quarterfinalist you want to really have
your work surface in a way that it
becomes undeniable and undeniable is a
word that you're going to hear me say a
lot because it's a big key term for the
industry work that is undeniable writers
who are undeniable that's who the
industry wants to work with so let's
take a hypothetical and tell me if this
might work suppose I'm a writer I live
in the Midwest and I have a relative or
a friend that has an LA address and so
I'm telling these Network Executives oh
I'm in LA and I'm trying to make it work
and squeak by can that really happen
suppose I say yeah I live in LA I can I
can what time do you need me there I
take a flight how realistic is that I'm
going to be able to keep that up until
I'm hired it's possible not probable
I've I've gotten calls for my writers by
somebody saying hey you work with such
and such right it's Friday it's 11 o' I
want this person in my office at two I
want to sign them before the weekend's
over get them over here and if you say
they can't do it that becomes a problem
wow um and also there's an issue of
honesty right you want to be as honest
as possible now I have a good friend
who's in Seattle who is a television and
feature writer who comes down on a
regular basis and takes meetings I have
writers in New York New York I do find
to be an advantageous location because
the industry travels to it a lot so they
opportunity to meet with potentially
your agent or your manager when they're
visiting New York um you know you want
to be as honest as you can about it
while being entirely available so the
thing is to say I'm in Seattle if you
let me know by 8:00 in the morning I can
be there too H okay right so aside from
the honesty part still being being able
to travel and making it work and being
able to move here if you get the job it
probably sounds like it wouldn't work
well the thing is that writers who are
remote to Los Angeles should expect
regular trips to Los Angeles at their
own expense um initially before the rer
is repped it's going to be to come out
here to potentially attend conferences
or classes or events start to get to
know their writing class then when they
when they are repped come to meet their
reps um and then start going out on
General meetings that their rep sets up
for them so you know when I have ERS
coming in from the East Coast sometimes
I don't even get to see them because
they're literally booked from Monday
morning at 9:00 in the morning all the
way through to Friday at 5:00 P pm.
sometimes into the weekend with
back-to-back meetings and that's
something that any writer who's not in
Los Angeles should expect to take on
should their material hit and that's
really what we want right because the
way that a writer breaks today is not
quite as linear as write a script sell
the script get the money it's write the
script use the script to introduce you
to Los Angeles introduce you to the
industry in the context of General
meetings so that's where the writer will
get to go out on a lot of generals meet
with a lot of people and for that you
certainly want to be able to do that do
that consistently sometimes do it every
few months um you know when things get
really really hot then potentially do it
every month um those are the things that
a writer needs to be able to deliver on
and agents and managers tend to look for
those red flags that signal whether or
not the writer is going to be available
to be in Los Angeles as much as it's
going to be required in order for them
to get a career off the ground okay
another hypothetical and that is someone
has a family trip and they're going to
come to LA and they want to get a feel
of the landscape they plan to be
pitching scripts they may even come and
move out here what would you say is a
good self tour for them well I always
tell writers who come into town from
another location and occasionally I'll
have a writer from Australia saying I
want to come to LA with a family or
without uh but come to Los Angeles how
do I do it best the way that I usually
advise Riders to do it is to plan their
trip around an event so that they have a
natural destination in which they can go
they can meet other writers they can
potentially meet industry people so
whether you are coming for one of the
big pitch events that take place in the
summer or you are coming for a
conference like the produced by
conference that puts you face Toof face
with the industry you want to plan a
visit around that and then look for
other networking events that are
happening around that get to know the
landscape that way um but have those
anchoring events that that really inform
your visit as opposed to show up and go
I'm here anybody um so yeah so i' like
to have visits anchored by events as
many as possible and then you know
usually the the good thing about Los
Angeles is that we do have networking
events that are happening all the time
so in any given week you can find Isa
Thursday night social you can go to that
happens once a month we have script
writers Network that has Friday night
drinks we have Blacklist that puts on
events so final draft does all of these
organizations put on networking and
socializing events for writers as well
as what happens regularly at the WJ
Foundation that puts on great panels um
and the list goes on and on so you
really want to Anchor your trip with an
event and then find networking events
around those so that you can start to
get to know not only Executives that you
want to work with agents and managers
you'd like to have rep you but other
writers who are themselves breaking in
who may have amassed a little bit more
information than you have so fun so far
and really help you learn the lay of the
land okay so let's take this
screenwriter who's arrived in town maybe
they found a networking event on Twitter
eventful something and they show up what
are they doing how are they not being
too parasitic and creepy how are they
being not too introverted what's the
right balance you know I'm going to take
this back to an anecdote um a friend of
the families um of mine and my husbands
as a director and my husband's not in
the industry and and this director sat
down with us for brunch one day and told
my husband how he was going in all these
generals this is a director who's done a
big movie for Fox etc etc and my husband
said to him I I don't understand what do
you do you go on all these generals what
do you do what what's the point and he
said my point is to get these people to
like me and that is what networking is
all about it's to get people to connect
with you and like you so it's not about
getting to know everybody it's not about
meeting every last person it's not about
giving your business card to every last
person but finding a few people to
connect with to exchange experiences
with to be real to be interesting
because the interesting thing about this
industry is that it's not just an
industry it's also a lifestyle people
who participate in it participate in it
often times 24 hours a day seven days a
week so they want to work and help
promote and help boost other people that
they like so it is about making those
genuine connections with people who
potentially will help you along will
give you some information potentially in
the beginning they'll only read your
script and give give you some notes but
then they may get ripped and then they
may offer to introduce you to their
agent to their manager so it really is
about building relationship networking I
think has gotten a bum wrap um it it has
the sticky icky feeling of you know I
have to sell myself somehow it's not
about that it's about connecting with
people it's about forging relationships
and doing it effortlessly usually the
best way to network is in the spirit of
generosity what can I do for you what
can I offer you what may do I have that
could be interesting to you forget what
you can do for me so finding those
relationships finding people that you
can talk to and potentially whether you
offer them and you don't have to offer
everyone to everything always but
whether there's information life
experience that you can share that will
inform something that they're writing
that will inform something they're
producing that goes a long way so it
really is about listening a lot
inquiring a lot um learning about that
other person and building those bonds so
that suddenly when that one networking
event is over that person that you just
met met emails you later that night and
says oh by the way there's another
Meetup it's people don't really know
about it but if you want to come had a
great time meeting you tonight um so it
is about building those bonds and
building those relationships I was
talking earlier today to a client of
mine who just sold a a show to
NBC and this client was speaking of all
the people who' have come out of the
woodwork that she hasn't talked to in 10
or 15 years who just dropped her an
email saying hey I heard you sold the
show would you st me oh nice and uh we
talked about the fact that nobody would
staff somebody they haven't talked to in
15 years or they've only met once but
they would stff or they would at least
consider somebody that they know and
like so the fostering of relationships
is really what networking is about in
this industry building and maintaining
relationships with people starts with
one or two and it grows from there um
it's about having five six 10 meaningful
relationships as opposed to knowing
everybody in town and not having them
know you back
yeah I think we've almost lost the art
of that a little bit because it's so
easy to look someone up on social media
or online just find out what they do and
then just go ride in for the pitch
instead of just being human so it sounds
like just still remaining human
remembering that it's a person they're
ordering drinks or food or whatever and
you're still in this little bar or
wherever it is an event absolutely and
not instead going for the big ask or the
big pitch I prefer you know I always
tell my clients I don't want you to ask
for anything if people like you they
will
offer if you ask even if they say yes
they're likely not going to
deliver because they're not invested but
if they like you they will offer all on
their own you know agents and managers
talk about it a lot what their
networking is like because they're in
breakfast lunch dinner drinks daily
nobody likes to be sold to right nobody
likes that experience of I'm just
selling you something now and then go on
to your next meeting and where you'll be
sold again so it is about remembering
the details about the other person on
the other side of the table and agents
and managers will speak to that they
will sit down they will talk for an hour
about how's the wife and how's the kids
and what are you doing and are you still
hand gliding remembering those details
and really building those relationships
then permits them at the end of that
lunch after the hour had passed to say
and by the way there's this one writer I
really want to talk to you about at that
point there's an exchange that
everybody's comfortable with because
there's enough of a foundational
relationship that allows for that to
occur what a lot of writers forget and
what a lot of people forget because of
the nervousness that networking inspires
is that your job is really to connect
it's to build relationships you don't
build relationships with an ask you
build it with a give and often times you
build it from learning about the other
person rather than just informing them
about
you what is the screenwriting path to
failure I love that question oh good
okay I actually adore that question cuz
I think everybody has this idea of
failure but nobody knows what it is
right I'm going to fail and it's going
to I'm going to go down in flames and
you're no you're not the only failure in
screenwriting is a not writing I wrote a
script five years ago I'm running around
with this one script I haven't touched a
typewriter or computer since then for
any creative purposes that is
screenwriting failure not writing new
content not generating new content
harping on Old content not getting notes
huge huge huge in the failure of things
if you are tunnel visioned and this is
how it has to be and anything short of
this as I saw it on the page arrives on
the screen then it will be my failure
you will fail in that because this is
while writing is solitary this is a
highly collaborative industry so the
road to failure is not writing not
writing new material not getting notes
wanting to be perfect there is no
perfection in this industry it is all
about getting notes learning from notes
getting notes that you hate figuring out
what to do with them um because other
people are people are going to have to
buy in so the road to failure is really
being stunted stinted stunted stinted um
well what is I'm sorry to interrupt you
what what is being too perfect because I
think a lot of people that try to be too
perfect they don't realize it so what is
that um it's always thinking
that it can be better and you know most
work can be better but there is a point
of diminishing returns right there is a
point where you are just switching
around your word smithing and you're
really the returns are you improve it by
a percent by half of a percent that's
not going to do it so when is the work
ready when is it strong enough when do
you believe in your work and a lot of
writers feel very very confident writing
but not confident at all getting the
work out there so at some point you have
to understand okay this is what it is
this is what I wanted it to be I'm a big
believer in feedback so getting feedback
from people that you trust um who who
have some experience and knowledge in
the industry be they other working
writers or Consultants like Michael heg
or Jen granti that You' have talked to
um or script readers that are known for
being really hard on the work when they
say you know what it's good get it out
there at some point you have to let go
at some point you have to say yeah I can
fuss with it forever and you can I
promise you that you can and I've seen
writers do it and I've had fights with
writers who've done it who just would
harp on the same script you have to
accept it for the potential that it has
you have to question whether or not
you've realized that potential did you
do what you wanted to do with the script
did you write the story that you wanted
to tell is it being received in the
manner that you wanted it to be received
so are people getting it are they
connecting with it are they enthused by
it if the anwers to that is yes then you
get it out there as much as rejection is
part of the job and it is part of the
job you are going to get rejected and so
you better grow it or develop a tougher
skin you will be rejected get it out
there the point is to get that yes and
you have to get through a lot of no
knows to get that yes but you have to
get the world out the work out there it
does no good for you on the Shelf it
does no good for you sitting on the
computer with without anybody seeing it
of course you want to scrutinize that
the work is up to par right you you want
to make sure that the work is strong and
you're getting the feedback that it's
strong enough for people that who don't
have to be nice to you um and that's a
really big thing so it can't just be
your friends who are concerned about
maintaining friendship right um who are
going to be a little bit more forgiving
because they understand your intention
they know what you went for you didn't
quite get there but they saw it enough
um but people who will scrutinize your
work and be demanding of it are telling
you it's good get it out there get it
out there that's how you build a career
you don't build a career with one script
that you're precious about you build a
career writing great script after great
script and getting people getting a fan
base that's excited about you that's
excited to read the next thing that
knows that the next thing is coming and
want to be the first on the list to get
it from
you well I think you've talked before
about this industry wants to be able to
work with people that are easy to work
with so if someone's receiving notes
what are some tips that they're
resistant whether it's in their body
language whether it's keywords they're
using and vice versa showing that
they're
open you always want
to really listen during a note session
it's not your time to defend the work
it's your time to listen to take the
physical notes to jot down thoughts
don't defend the work um you know I've
I've had occasions where writers were
given a note and an executive called out
something it was a problem and the
writer went it's not a problem I don't
think it's a problem do you think it's a
problem I don't think it's a problem
it's not a problem that sort of thing is
an obvious giveaway that the writer is
not listening um it's listening to the
notes it's listening to the note behind
the note um if there is something that
truly truly truly you think the
executive the person giving you notes
didn't get you can say well I tried to
illustrate that with this in this
particular scene was that not clear you
want to always ask those leading
questions to find out where you miss the
mark because ultimately the Mark was
missed can we assume that once in a
while an executive will miss something
yeah and usually they're pretty open to
oh I didn't realize that this connects
to that maybe we can do that better um
it's usually very easy to tell when a
writer is resistant to notes uh when the
writer is instantly defensive when the
writer becomes sarcastic or passive
aggressive um and there's a lot of
passive aggression that can come out in
a note session that like well I thought
not but fine um so you know i' I've seen
it in in notes sessions with my writers
and I've and I've given some brutal
notes and there have been people who
just sat down and jotted notes and said
okay let me go back and think about it
and there are people who with every not
would say well I don't know that I
necessarily agree with that but fine um
so you have those little cues that you
know you know in a minute body language
first um dismissal there can be a
judgment of the individual giving notes
well you you're a woman so naturally you
would think that I've certainly gotten
that that feedback um or any anything
that has to do with your you're a woman
you're a mother um I've gotten that well
you're you're a mother so clearly you
couldn't relate to that no I'm a human
being um try for a writer taking notes
try not to dismiss the no Giver um
because ultimately all that does is
sabotage the relationship because what
you're saying is yes you took the time
you did the work you read the script and
now you're giving me your thoughts but
I'm going to dismiss them because
suddenly something about you makes you
not good enough to give those notes
you're a mother you're a woman you're
white you're black you're whatever you
are but it's really important not to
dismiss the not Giver especially not in
front of the not Giver um so that there
can be a dialogue often times a writer
can receive a note and be perplexed by
the note but the thing then is to look
for the note behind the note okay you
gave me a note about X but does it
really have to do with why is this
what's bothering you and you can
certainly explore that in a conversation
you want there to be a dialogue and you
want to build a kind of trust where the
note Giver knows that you're listening
you're paying attention you're taking
those notes so that when you say you
know there's one thing here that's
bumping me can we talk about that a
little bit that's not defensive that's
thoughtful saying there's the one thing
I I agree with your list of 20 other
notes totally hear you we're good but
there's the one thing here and it's
bumping me can we go back to that for a
minute what was it about this character
this scene this pivot this escalation
that bumped you what what was it that
felt inauthentic was it that could it be
something else that to me is dialogue
and it's differentiating between
shutting down the note Giver which can
be done physically just you know I'm no
longer interested it can be done
verbally um
or getting into a more collaborative
environment which is what Executives
want to work with they don't want the
writer to be a yes person there's a
difference between being a yes person
and being
collaborative being collaborative will
require some push back on occasion and
that's okay but you better be really
thoughtful about your push
back you know that is somebody that
people want to work with I didn't you
suggested X I didn't do X because
ultimately I thought it would affect the
script this way but the note behind the
note implied that y would work so I
tried that this time that's being
collaborative that's not being a yes
person and the truth of the matter is
that a lot of writers think that they're
given notes and the executive just wants
them to implement the note verbatim I
find that to be very rarely the case um
if that was it the executive would be a
writer um you know they're giving
they're throwing out ideas they're
trying different things and they want
you to try them on for size and see
whether they work or they not they don't
work so if there's a note that they gave
on a previous draft that you didn't
Implement they want you to be able to
answer why you didn't Implement they
want you to be able to say well I tried
that and the way that it affected the
script was this and because of that I
realized it didn't work and I took it
out but I did something else to offset
your
note wouldn't they want a yes person no
why because they want the writer to
bring their creative juices to it that's
why they hire a
writer with a specific story
sensibility with a particular skill set
with a particular taste level for a
particular project right they want
somebody who will bring their unique
sensibilities to the project otherwise
hire a typist get the script hire a
typist and have the typus type in
whatever needs to be typed in they want
and of course there are the few
executives that are known around town
for being really locked into their notes
and they want their notes implemented
the way they want them implemented and
that's it and it's not a conversation
but by and large I find
that the creative execs executive
producers producers development execs
are all looking for a creative partner
as opposed to just somebody to execute
on the page they can get their assistant
to execute on the page they don't need
you for that they would be much better
off giving the material to their
assistant who has a bachelor's in in
English Lit to implement some changes
then going back and forth with you they
don't want you to be a yes person they
want you to provide your unique story
sensibilities your unique writerly touch
to make their notes that can be quite
shitty come off sing singing off the
page how are you softening some of the
screenwriters that you're working with
or maybe you're not that are either too
defensive or they're too to mayi pami of
a yes person um it it is a balancing act
so I think that once writers start
getting notes and a lot of notes they
they learn they learn because you're
going to get notes that are outright
offensive to you for what you've written
but you learn to take the good with the
bad um you you know I always tell
writers as they prepare for the industry
go find people who will hate your work
those are the people whose notes you
want you don't the people who tell you
how brilliant you are and how perfect it
is you're not going to learn anything
from that you're going to learn how to
take notes from getting notes that are
really offensive and finding something
in there that you can use what is the
core of that what is the what is the
little kernel inside that note that you
can take and do something with and
really move the material forward with
and listen I remember this from my days
of being a writer getting notes and just
getting infuriated and coming back and
going okay there was something there
what is that thing that's there what is
the note Giver really saying so you want
to really teach writers to take notes to
be receptive to finding that kernel that
truth that is in every note or in most
notes you also want to work with writers
and the way that I work with writers is
not giving them the answers when they're
going okay so there's this note and I'm
going to execute it that way is that
good no figure out your way to execute
that note and I get writers coming back
to me there there was one note that said
this how do I implement it you figure it
out you're on your own I'll sit with you
and I'll brainstorm with you once you
have the
direction but it has to be your
direction and that's where you have to
listen to your inner writer right you
have to really Foster your talent your
sensibilities of course it has to be
malleable you have to be able to work
with other people's sensibilities but
the key to being a great writer is
taking other people's ideas and making
them your own and falling just as in
love with them and being just as
invested in them as you would be had the
idea the concept originated with you
because the reality today is that you
know 2014 1800 people WJ members made
income in the film industry roughly 132
scripts sold what does that mean that
means that over 1,600 people made their
money writing Pages doing writing
assignments so how do you become that
writer who does writing assignment
Simonson does it successfully you're
able to take a kernel of an idea and
make it your own and fall in love with
it and really take it and run with it in
a way that makes other people want to
work with
you what do you say to screenwriters
that are afraid someone will steal
either their idea or their finished
script this is really so unsexy get over
it it's it
really there really is nothing for the
industry to gain from stealing work if
you're a brand new writer and you wrote
something that is the greatest idea ever
the industry is much better off you're
not a wga member buying that script from
you for 25 Grand 30 grand maybe 50 Grand
and doing whatever they want to with it
as opposed to potentially getting tied
up in lawsuits it really doesn't pay
anybody to steal work in the industry
and you can't come at the industry from
a place of mistrust you can't come at
agents and managers saying well I'll
send you my work but I'm really nervous
because I've heard about how scripts get
stolen because then you're coming at it
from a place of I automatically do not
trust you the industry I am the writer
you're going to victimize me nobody
wants to work with that nobody wants to
deal with that and the reality is that
when bridesmaids came out I can't tell
you how many writers came to me and said
oh my God I wrote that exact same script
there are ideas that are zyy there are
ideas that are in the moment um and
those ideas tend to manifest in many
different places but it really does not
serve you in any way to think that the
industry will steal your work your job
with your script that you have if you're
writing outside of the industry and all
likelihood if you have a feature script
the job of that feature script is to get
you an agent to get you a manager that's
its job it likely won't sell as it is to
the industry we're in in Industry the
2016 we are likely to sell less than 100
specs that's not a big number if you're
aiming for that Bullseye that is a
narrow narrow narrow Bullseye you want
to use that script to get your an agent
to get your manager to introduce you to
the industry to get on the prestige
lists that's what you want that script
to do for you and in order to do that
you have to expose the work so get over
any idea that somebody will steal your
script because that's just not going to
happen and and the rare rare rare rare
occasions that it
has the writer usually got their their
own success in their own way well let's
continue with mistrust because I think
on your screenwriting blog for your
website Lee jess.com you have a post
entitled screenwriters leave your
mistrust at the door M and I know some
of us are way more trusting than others
some are maybe more on the naive scale
but you talked about some some things
that a lot of people I think would be
afraid of like they want me to sign a
release form I mean that's scary that's
that that's a little scary or um I think
this one we're kind of touching on that
screenplay has the same concept of mine
somebody stole my idea wouldn't they
rather cheat me than pay me so how do
you work with someone that's already
coming with those set of
fears and make them so that they're
little more workable um but not naive
not not a doormat I always tell my
writers that I'm the same the safe space
so you can let out all your neurosis and
I'll put you in your place so I actually
wrote that particular blog post after a
writer of mine um had finished a script
the script had made had had been entered
into one contest hadn't placed um and
another script with Eerie similarities
sold Eerie Eerie Eerie similarities and
the writer came to me and said what am I
to make of this and we had to kind of
sit back and say okay here's where the
script was here's the writer who just
sold a
script here's there is no as much as I
understand their Eerie similarities
let's talk through what the probability
would be of this writer an established
writer with the summer
blockbuster would have of stealing your
script let's talk through it so I always
tell my writers I'm a safe space we need
to talk about it but at some point a
writer either wises up or not so I
worked with a writer for a while that I
no longer work with who refused to pitch
any ideas talk log lines or anything as
such in a public environment so in a
coffee shop in a bar which is where a
lot of Industry meetings take place mind
you the writer refused to do it because
somebody would listen and somebody would
still his steal his idea and it became
uncomfortable and so at some point I had
to say to the writer listen you're going
to have managers meeting you there was a
manager that wanted to meet with that
writer in a coffee shop so the manager
is going to ask you what else do you
have what are you going to say I can't
tell you here I'll send you an email
doesn't work that way so at some point
even if you have it innately you have to
set it aside you have to because this
industry works the way that it does with
the idea of trust and respecting the
creative mind the creative brain the
originator of content if you originated
a great idea a great script a great
story why would I steal it from you why
wouldn't I just take the thing that's
already done and do something with it
wouldn't that make more sense for me if
I'm a producer or an executive why would
I steal it get somebody else to write it
potentially for more money because they
are already well known either they
execute it well or they don't maybe they
don't or somebody else does the same
thing before my script is done why
wouldn't I just pick it up from you the
the creator of content who came up with
this great concept what incentive do I
an executive have to steal it from you
and that's what a lot of writers have to
despite how frustrating it can get have
to look at and that's ultimately what
that writer and myself had to look at
when a script with Eerie similarities to
his sold there was no way for the
manager who sold that script to get that
script there was no way that an industry
executive had read that script it had
been submitted to one place 3 months
before there was just no no reality in
which the script was stolen
Rewritten what the writer had to
acknowledge was that ultimately if I'm
the manager right behind the script sale
and I here I got let's let's assume I
got a completed script that is great
that I think I can sell and I have this
writer who just had a box office success
what is my best way of making the most
money my best way of making the most
money is getting the one script that I
just got that's ready to sell and
selling it and booking my writer who
just had a big box office success on a
writing assignment and making more money
why limit the ways in which I'm making
money by having the writer than take the
script and try to make money off of it
rather than monetize both so those are
the equations that writers have to look
at is it really in the industry's best
interest to steal content I really don't
find that it
is I think this is another blog post of
yours but I wanted to expand on it sure
so writers are great it
explaining in someone else's story but
what about their own especially when it
comes to presenting themselves to the
world to the studio
system what is that refining of Their
Own Story what is too much how truthful
do they be you want a writer to be
truthful when they talk about themselves
but you have to also remember that a
writer's first story is their own so if
they don't know how to tell their story
it's going to be tough to trust them
with other stories so you really have to
figure out where where is the juice in
your story it's never in chronology or
very rarely in chronology if you travel
to space sure chronology is just fine um
but it is about finding a way to connect
your Human Experience for lack of better
words to the person who's sitting across
ring to become interesting to become
unique to tell them a story they haven't
heard that is truthful and yours and it
can be completely anecdotal um you know
I've certainly talked to people who
start out saying I have I've never done
anything interesting in my life
well then what's your point of view on
the things that you've done what have
you made of your experiences um to find
those stories that really speak to who
you are as a person and a writer um to
tell something interesting and unique so
that a month later a month after a
general with an executive be it in a
production company or a studio that
executive looks at a piece of work and
says hey what happened to the writer who
the writer who had that experience I can
bring into this one um you know so it is
about sharing the those experiences
those points of view um and finding a
way to tell that personal
story that is Meaningful and that is
connective and that isn't tied up in a
bow doesn't have to be pretty it has to
be memorable and eloquent you have to be
comfortable talking about it so it can't
turn into a therapy session um you know
but it has to be that story that nobody
else has to tell so you know for a while
everybody was talking about writers who
would go into networks and talk about
how television was their only friend
we've heard a lot of those stories so
those stories are no longer unique every
writer every person has an experience
has a point of view that is uniquely
theirs you don't have to take half an
hour to tell to tell it in fact we want
it told in 2 minutes in three minutes
the most but relate to us something that
we can remember that speaks to who you
are because that's who we want to work
with you know I have a writer who is
super talented lovely lovely woman very
very shy who came to me and said I don't
know what my personal story is and I
can't really talk about it and so I had
to bring in a lot of
anecdotes there were a lot of different
stories and they all came out kind of
sad and the problem was that she's a
comedy writer till one day she brought
me a story about her mother she's Korean
she grew up naturally with a Korean
mother who was obsessed with not
wrinkling her face so she taught herself
how to laugh without moving any of the
muscles on her face so that she would
never
age and so she told she taught my client
to do the same thing fast forward 20
years my client is a comedy writer what
does that tell you of course she told it
with a little bit more flare and detail
but those are the kind of stories that
stick that are unique that are memorable
that nobody else has those are the
stories that you want to share with the
industry because they'll remember you
that way okay so if someone's
envisioning their story and how they may
EXP explain it first off how will they
or in what arena will they be telling
this story like when would it ever come
up to say hey you know what Lee tell me
about yourself I've seen what you've
written but I want to know your deal in
every general
meeting an executive will sit you down
and literally say so tell me about
yourself just like that um we talked
earlier I I was doing a lot of
interviews for this book that I just
written and in that environment I'd gone
in to meet with agents managers
Executives I've never met with before I
can't tell you how many times folks that
I was interviewing would sit down with
me and say so Lee tell me about
yourself those are the moments that it's
asked and it's in every General it's in
every opportunity who are you is there
anything for us to connect on is it the
story that you tell is it the way that
you tell that story is it the
sensibility with which you see the world
so it's in every general meeting every
last general meeting tell me about
yourself other than what else do you
have it's perhaps the most popular
question in this industry Lee where
would someone actually be telling their
story and how deep do they go how light
do they keep it can I Envision the
scenario as to how someone's going to be
asking about me sure um often times it's
going to happen in a general meeting it
niceties bottle of water tell me about
yourself can I get you something to
drink tell me about yourself it's very
blunt and upfront and do your show um
you know I have writers who have
different versions of their stories um
so I have one writer who suffered a
traumatic event in her childhood and if
she is meeting with somebody that she
feels an in instant bond and trust with
then she will go deeper she will go
darker with others she will leave the
nitty-gritty out so you tailor your
story a little bit to see what in how
dark you want to go wear but the rule is
never make it a therapy session never
bring in a story that you're not ready
ready to talk about openly without
breaking down without having a moment of
tears all of that is unnecessary because
a lot of specifically in TV TV really
looks at what do you bring into the room
right it's not just what your writing is
but what personal experience what themes
speak to you what what do you bring with
you into the writer's room so they want
to know that you're capable of talking
about whatever it is you're bringing
comfortably that it's not going to be a
therapy session that there's not going
to be suddenly an elephant in the room
that makes everybody UNC comfortable so
you want to have those layers to the
story comedy writers tend to really look
for the lighter fluffier happier stuff
or the really dark stuff told in a very
funny way uh you know tragedy via comedy
um but drama writers tend to have those
more layered stories that they choose
How Deeply to go into um you know so if
it's being abandoned by your father is
it you know the life of petty crime
you're forced into a 12 and how cute you
were getting away with it or was it the
nights that you spent alone and when you
didn't have money to pay for electricity
and what that felt like and what it felt
like when Social Services showed up and
tried to uproot you from your home those
are different ways to tell the same
story um so writers really do pick and
choose and it's important that you
assess your environment to really
determine which version of which story
you're telling um ultimately it's always
going to be the same story because
you're going to get known for that story
and then there'll be other anecdotes
that will come along with it
um but it really is about finding that
core story and taking it out there and
getting the industry to know you through
it okay so different versions maybe have
an A B and C version yeah you have you
know you have the kind
of deep version where you where you
really kind of drill into the story and
then you have your more for lack of
better words shallow version of it that
is less confrontational less demanding
of The Listener less uncomfortable
potentially um it really is how you look
at it some some writers prefer to not
expose any sort of wound when they talk
about a personal story they're perfectly
happy to stay surfacy and and just
allude to a wound but it really is about
planning it and rehearsing it and
exploring it so that when you go into a
room that's not when you're Excavating
your own story and figuring out what's
what
works Lee I finished my screenplay very
excited about it I'm ready to get it out
there what am I supposed to do so it's
going to be different for reped writers
and rep writers vaguely the same steps
but different mechanics if you will um
for a rept writer you the one the one
kind of Step that will happen for both a
reped writer and unrep writer is that
you want to really vet the work so you
want to get people looking at it whether
it's writers in your writers group who
are all working writers whether it's a
consultant that you pay a fee to or a
reader you want to really make sure that
in my world I don't want a rep to see a
script that hasn't been vetted I'm just
not comfortable with it
um so you really want to vet it make
sure that it's holding up that enough
people are having the right response to
it as opposed to saying well it's a pass
for me but here's what worked about it
if it's a pass for them across the board
it's a problem so you want to really vet
it make sure that it's holding up that
it's really strong um now if you're a
rept writer let's say you're looking for
new representation you're going to give
it to your other writer friends you're
going to give it to agents and managers
that you've met previously see how they
respond to the work if if you're an
unrep writers you're going to give it to
your circle of friends see if any of
them gets inspired by it you're not
asking them for an introduction you're
asking them for a read you can also go
out and build pedigree for it which
means you're going to answer the
question why should I read the script so
how do you answer that you answer it
with some element that certifies your
script as ready for the industry that
can be The Blacklist the website that
can be spec Scout which is another
website it can be a big contest all of
those are filtering services that are in
place for the industry to filter through
thousands and thousands of screenplays
that are registered on a regular basis
but how do you find the great scripts
among them that's where contest comes in
that's where television writing
fellowships come in screenwriting Labs
come in um and websites like The
Blacklist that are able to provide
evaluations and rank the script um so
you try to build some pedigree
specifically if you're an unknown
writer in order to answer the question
why should I read the script
I have 120 scripts sitting in my queue
you just queried me about one I've never
heard of why in the world should I read
it cuz it's good as just not good enough
so having the ability to say well this
was a nickel semi-finalist or this got
an eight on The Blacklist or I was just
a finalist for the ABC Disney Fellowship
all of those things are the reasons why
one should read the script in addition
to that once you have a little bit of
pedigree as an unknown writer you want
to start getting the work out there so
you want to to get it out to your
friends who can potentially help you get
the work to agents managers you want to
pitch the work so whether you want to
participate in live pitch events that
happen in Los Angeles in Austin also a
little bit in London or do online
pitching that's stage 32 and road map
writers provide year round you want to
start talking about the work and getting
it out there that is your job your job
is to get reject rejected if you don't
get enough rejections you're not doing
your job if you're afraid of that no
stop being afraid um but really your job
is to use that script to build
relationships for yourself yes you want
to enter it into contests because if
you're not able to get any interest
pitching the material in 6 months time
if you're able to place well in a
contest it will give your script Second
Wind um I have one writer who was just a
finalist in Austin now was a finalist
for final draft was a finalist for page
um he had written a script that his
agent ultimately didn't respond to at
all put the script into a bunch of
contests placed well in all those
contests now there're suddenly interest
for management other people want to talk
to him about it he's not writing for an
audience of one he's no longer just
writing for an agent to say yay or nay
um so you want to take that script and
use it to build inroads to
opportunity okay let's suppose I've put
it out there either I'm repped or unrep
and there's no heat on it then you have
to take a look and say okay where where
is the problem sometimes the script just
will not get hit the heat that it
requires because who knows
um you look at something like Nick Yo's
um a letter from rosemary
Kennedy that was a semi-finalist in the
nickel and then nothing and then I went
on the The Blacklist website and was a
featured screenplay and nothing until
somebody discovered it now the writer is
with WME Emma Stone is attached to the
material to Star um you know at some
point you have to have conviction in
your work one of the managers that I
love working with is a guy by the name
of Ross and one of the reasons I love
working with him is because once I asked
him I love him for many different
reasons but once I asked him if you send
a script to 50 people and everybody
passes what do you do and he said I find
the next 50 people and you have to have
that level of conviction in your work if
you the work is vetted if you know that
it's being received as intended so if
people in the know have read the work
and said yeah it's great it's really
great I love it you have to fight for it
um and listen there's some great scripts
that you fight for that nothing happens
with and then that that other script
that you think will never be as good at
is the is the one that hits but you have
to fight for the work you have to
believe in the work nobody's going to
believe in it more than you and yes some
scripts will come up short we don't know
why we don't have the perfect
explanation you know I have a writer who
wrote a great feature this is a rept
writer um wrote a great great great
feature script very dark um that had to
do with police violence and ultimately
then Dallas happened and so everybody
looked at the writer and said yeah
really good script congratulations not
going to do anything with it those
things happen and that's okay um but you
have to fight for the script as much as
you can unless there is some sort of
impediment that's stopping it from
proceeding forward like that meanwhile
while you're fighting for the script you
better be writing your next one so that
if it does open that door and people say
great I read it love your writing what
else do you have you have that thing to
give but you have to fight for every
script you have to pitch it because if
you don't believe it in it enough to
pitch it to fight for it to invest in it
why should anybody
else continuing on with fighting for the
work suppose you're working with someone
that come to you and you either have
someone who's very sort of uh
self-deprecating almost mousike or
someone who's more of an overconfident
bragger either one's probably
detrimental getting their work out yes
so what are your rules for sort of
either breaking down the bragger or
maybe you're not or boosting up the
mouse well with with the mouse I just
talked to one such Mouse this morning um
who takes every failure every know as as
a testament to her own lifelong
predestined failure and so I have very
hard brutal conversations about the fact
there there will be a lot of rejection
there will be a lot of NOS at every
level at every level of this industry
nothing's ever perfect nothing's ever
just handed to you and so it's important
to me to have a lot of candid
conversations about learning not to take
the nose with quite as much
weight uh because if you do it's just
never ending right it's it's just a
recipe for disaster um so we talk a lot
about conviction in the work believing
in your work believing in your potential
not needing to rely on other people for
your own selfworth because really that's
what it boils down to um and so we talk
about that a lot and we talk about
fattening up people's lives um so making
sure that my writers who are mousy um
have their sources their Dependable
sources of fun that it's not all about
the writing all the time because the
other side of it is if it's just the
writing if it's all about the writing
all the time and nothing else eventually
they'll have nothing else to invest in
the writing itself they'll have nothing
to bring to the writing so it's really
kind of filling out their lives and
making sure that that they're fulfilled
on many different levels and it's not
just the writing that defines them
because if it's only the writing that
defines you a you will become a very
boring writer and B it will never be
fulfilling enough ever and I've seen
that a million times Hemingway committed
suicide you know there's something to
learn there um and so the ones who are
tend to be a little bit more braggy um
tend to be a little bit more
egotistical um a a bit more full of
themselves we'll talk a lot about how
their behavior is coming
off and I will do a lot of meeting prep
with them and talk about you know the
way that you're talking about
that to me comes off a certain way and
you may want to pay attention to these
things that's why I'm here I'm here to
reflect that and be a mirror to those
things um and so we'll certainly talk
about how those things come off and that
we can't afford that um nobody wants to
work with somebody who is just
completely full of themselves I had
recently a conversation with a manager
about a a client of mine that he
represents and he says you know I think
this client is just couldn't care less
about my opinion and I said well
actually I think it's quite the contrary
I think that he's desperate to impress
you and I think because of that he may
be coming off a little bit bigger and
more boastful but it's out of
desperation to get you on his side to
get get you to Rally behind him it's not
for lack of respect it's because of
respect that he's behaving that way so
many times writers don't have me as a
go-between um to communicate to their
agent or their managers or the executive
that they're working with so a lot of it
is me talking to them about listen this
is how I'm reading you right now I know
it doesn't sound fun and I'm sorry to
say this and I love you and I know what
a great person you are but this is how
I'm reading this is this how you want me
to read this CU if you're fine with it
keep going but I'm reading your behavior
as
that of one who is smarter than anybody
else in the room nobody wants to work
with that can I hear some examples let's
suppose conversations with the
self-deprecating writers conversations
with the bragger because maybe this
person doesn't recognize who they are um
a
bragger the most obvious and overt ones
are the braggers that will come in and
say and these are usually not
professional writers because
professional writers don't do this and
have learned better and have broken
because they don't but it has happened
this is the greatest script you're ever
going to
read that's a big statement I am the
Michael Jordan of
screenwriting whoa hold on I've had
these are things that have been said to
me for the record you
know this this is the script you've been
waiting
for take the script somebody told me
once take the script on vacation this is
my vacation gift to you oh how kind read
it I want you to sit at sunset read it
on The Veranda because this will make
your vacation great um so those things
have been said to me um you know you
want to steer clear
of this is the great this is the best
script ever you can certainly say this
is the greatest thing I've ever written
I'm really proud of it I've worked
really hard at it you know I have eight
scripts behind me and this is my best
one that's not bar
braggy that is genuine but somebody
coming in and saying oh my God this is
so much better than anything else out
there I had one writer working writer no
longer working writer um who used to be
very very successful had fallen from
Grace a bit not a great deal um but who
used to every year write a list of all
the screenplays that were nominated for
Academy Awards and then write Arguments
for why why his script was better and
send it out in Christmas cards oh yeah
wow okay not a good idea just not a good
idea if you're saying to me that your
script that's unproduced that nobody
wanted to pick up that has been read by
everybody but nobody loved it is better
than
Argo you're H it's a problem um so
that's you know that's the baggery side
and and of course the examples I brought
in are a little bit on the ex extreme
side of it but I think you get the tone
of it um you know the most the more
self-de defeating
writers it usually is conversation
about I got this
rejection I know that I will never be
the person I want to be there's usually
a direct connection about what rejection
means about the person not about the
script or the person reading the
script I I'm not going to make it as a
writer I will never be happy I will
never be
fulfilled I'm just a loser I didn't make
it in this
contest I can't can't tell you the rhyme
or or Reason of screenwriting contests
I've been in this industry forever and I
still don't understand them and I have
writers saying oh I I didn't make the
quarterfinals in the nickel I'm a loser
I know that I'm a loser now I'm a bad
Rider hold on there's going to be lots
more rejections there's going to be lots
more opportunities to be a loser don't
jump at the chance so quickly but for a
lot of writers it's very real and don't
me wrong every writer has a moment or 15
of being self- defeatist you know I have
one writer who's a working writer who
always says that if you're not thinking
about quitting at least twice a week
you're doing something wrong and I
believe him I I think it's very very
true I think every writer thinks they're
failing at a moment every writer thinks
that they're not good enough every
writer thinks that they're never going
to be able to recreate the past success
that they've had I think that's
perfectly part of the deal but seeing
everything as a failure as an indication
that you are just a loser or you are
just a bad writer or you are just a bad
person that is what I see in the more
self- defeated defeated writers and the
problem is that nobody wants to work
with that nobody wants to be in a room
with that nobody wants to pick up your
script as a validation to who you are as
a human being they want to pick up your
script because it's a great script and
they want to bring you into the room
because they think you have something to
contribute not because they think that
you need the
room and that's that's a big
distinction so are you giving these
people pep talks or that's not really
what your job is about oh I give people
pep talks I'm I'm Israeli I'm married to
a New Yorker so there's a lot of tough
love in the
picture um you know admittedly I get a
lot of tears from a lot of people and I
want to be the safe space to that and
the place for writers to voice
frustrations and I certainly try to
support them through it you know they're
writers where if I see that we're
getting to a place where every time we
meet it's just horrible and the writer
is in pieces I will ask why in the world
are you doing this it's more important
to be happy than to be a writer what are
you doing um so I will I will have those
conversations there are pep talks there
is tough love um and there is a shoulder
to give I recognize that this is a
really really hard profession you know I
was talking to a writer this morning who
was really frustrated with a set of
notes that she had was given an
Implement on a pilot that she just sold
but the draft that she turned in she was
wasn't delighted with and it took a toll
on her because she really wants to do
the best at everything and it brought
her to question why am I doing this and
this is not her first time to the rodeo
and you know should I really keep going
because this happens every time and I
said to her you know what the day you
sold this pilot you called me on the
drive home after the pilot sold in the
room and you told me that this is one of
the happiest days of your life now
you're having a bad day this is not one
of the worst days of your life and
because of that you're going to keep
going
and that's the truth of the matter we're
all going to have bad days here and I'm
here to support my writers through them
but it's about understanding when
they're some bad days and when it's all
bad
days Lee I think you've said that
feature writers should have a new
readyto market feature script every six
months or so and that TV writer should
have a new original pilot every like 3
to four months in a perfect world yes
okay is that a lot of pressure though it
is a lot of pressure I find the most
features go 6 to 12 months
you know the truth of the matter is if
you take 14 months and you come out with
a great sample I'm not going to hold it
against you um you know the the
important thing for me is that you keep
writing and you keep finishing work uh
for pilots in a perfect world I would
like to see two generated in a year um
sometimes it happens that it's only one
sometimes it happens that it's three it
really depends on the writer so there
isn't one set course that you're
supposed to follow but it really is
about doing the work and then getting
the work out there sometimes you'll work
on a script and you'll say you know I've
worked on this for eight months I've
tackled it every which way it's not
happening so it's also knowing when to
let something go not for all eternity
but potentially to come back to it later
when you've had a stroke of Genius that
informs you how to take the work how to
make it better um you know but the point
with having those broad goals is to just
do the work and get it out there rather
than spend years and years and years
tinkering with one screenplay that then
you're at the risk of after three years
and I just went through this with a
writer tinkering with the same script
for three years and then going oh it's
not good enough it'll never be good
enough I'm not going to get it out there
and then starting another script and
spending another two years on something
and then going oh but it's still not
good enough I'm not going to get this
out there that is the challenge that we
run into that so because of that you
really want to expose the work early and
often so that means from concept you
want to run the concept by people in the
know whether they're members of your
writer's group or in a class or whatever
it is have people look at your outline
and really don't be afraid to expose the
work to get feedback to have questions
asked I was just sitting with a writer
of mine who had written a script a
feature script um with the guidance of
his manager um and they had been on the
script for a year and a half and then he
gave the script to a few writer friends
and he got some massive notes back and
what he said to me is if only we'd given
it out on outline which is what we all
were pushing him to do but he felt loyal
to the manager he didn't want to expose
it and I understand I understand the
choice that he made it was in in a tough
spot do you listen do you serve the one
master or do you open yourself up I
generally prefer to expose work early
and often because I think it just saves
you a lot of time in the
end is someone writing for themselves or
for the
industry that's a good question
somebody's writing the stories that they
love that they are passionate about I
don't believe in writing to the market
because ultimately you'll always be
behind um you know what you're writing
now if you're writing with what's you
know whatever is happening in the
industry right now in six months it's
going to be dated so I think writing to
the industry can be a losing battle um
while you should write with an awareness
of your audience who your audiences
whether it's television or film who
would watch this show where does the
show belong what season does this film
get released is this a summer
blockbuster is this an endof Year movie
is this a February movie is it going to
be a movie for 16 to 24 year olds or is
it going to be a movie for 49 year olds
and older what are we talking about you
should be aware of all of those things
but you shouldn't write to them I think
the moment that you try to engineer your
work towards something it loses its
Brilliance I know somebody a manager who
for a long time was working with his
girlfriend to engineer script for The
Blacklist for the list The Blacklist
ultimately that script was never
finished because it was engineered and
then the manager then came back and said
to me yeah we we tried to engineer it
clearly a bad idea um so you have to you
have to listen to your heart's song in
that sense you have to really write the
original exciting material that is
Uniquely Yours that that is the story
that you're dying to tell with some
awareness of how the market will or
won't receive it so if you want
to write a script that is going to be
full of singing and speaking eels it's
likely going to be a challenge um but if
you have to do it do it um but write it
in a way that is true for you write
write the story that you want to tell in
a way that is exciting to you but that
can be digested by the market that it's
for Lee can you share some stories of
writers that were unrep that went to
then become repped and worked in
television of course um
there too many good stories there is the
problem um but one of my favorite
stories that that is a story something
happened to a client of mine this past
year um this is a client um a writer
whom I met through
UCLA um we started working together he
then started taking classes at a program
called Script Anatomy that I'm a big fan
of um really perfected his work wrote a
fantastic pilot that ended up actually
coming um in second place in the
prestigious UCLA contest um using this
pilot he found a manager who decided to
shop the pilot which is highly unlikely
today to shop a pilot from a brand new
writer um but he found a manager a very
well-known and well respected manager um
who took out the script they went on a
bunch of meetings and a bunch of
networks
ultimately at that point nothing had
come come of it um but he continued to
network pretty aggressively and in a
pretty focused fashion he is Latino and
he went to a panel of Latino writers and
had prepped for the panel before it had
happened um and so he walked in knowing
a little bit about each one of the
panelists he tried to communicate with
three of the four um those three he
couldn't really make any sort of
connection with but the fourth writer he
really HIIT it off with um ultimately he
felt like he didn't want to stalk the
writer he didn't want to be the guy
going can you read my script um so he
befriended him on Facebook and Twitter
and that was was the end of it few
months passed and he realized that this
writer was teaching a class at writing
pad um which is a writing program um and
said you know I'm going it's it's a prep
class for the television fellowships I
want to go sign up for the class because
as part of this class this writer is
going to have to read my work the writer
read his work called him up and said hey
I think I know of an opportunity for
you it turned out the opportunity was
Staffing on American Crime season 3 the
most prestigious show on network
television based on the writer's
personal story the writer went on to
meet with the executive producer of the
show and then went on to have a call
with John Ridley um he had no in the
room experience he was then called in to
meet with ABC Disney's inclusion
Department which subsidizes the
fellowship um they all signed off on him
and three days before the room opened he
got the call that he is Staffing on this
show um I I really love this story
because I feel like it takes the onus of
getting that first job out of the agent
or manager's hand the writer is now
signed with
CAA um writing feverishly seeing him
tomorrow at 8:00 in the morning um you
know hard at work he he just finished
his season of American Crime where he
had a co-write so he had a he had a
co-written by credit on his own episode
EP um you know just as euphoric as can
be love the experience but it's a writer
who really made it happen for himself
rather than saying okay I have an agent
I have a manager I'm going to sit on my
hands and wait uh for something like
that to happen so I particularly love
that story um because it it just shows
you what a writer who is smart about
networking can do for
himself um and you know he went from a
complete unknown taking classes in UCLA
to a rep and working
writer so that's interesting because I
think a lot of people that are signed
are going to feel like they're that's
where their work stops in terms of them
having a search so can you dispel that
myth supposed absolutely signed by one
of the bigger agencies and they feel
like okay now I've arrived but really
not the interesting thing is that most
writers who get repped right even in the
bigger on the the kind of bigger
landscape with a bigger agency CA WME
UTA I
if they truly stop and ask their agent
and manager or their agent so are you
going to get me a job most of them are
going to tell them getting you your
first job is not my responsibility that
is the truth of the matter so writers
have to continue to network to get
themselves out there so for example I
had a writer who was won the UCLA
contest on both the feature or the the
TV original TV pilot and spec
front as you do um got an A manager
through that then went on and got into
two fellowships in one year got a
manager and an agent ultimately got her
job through her Fellowship but her
management was instrumental in
introducing her to her showrunner who
then paid for her out of pocket which is
pretty non-standard when it comes to the
writing programs that are supposed to
subsidized some of these staff writer
roles um so I find that writers when
writers get repped especially with a
manager but it's also true with an agent
there's always ongoing work whether it's
networking whether it's doing showrunner
meetings not getting the job and then
getting the the you know the the
all the gift that is the freelance the
freelance script on the TV season um so
there's a lot of work to be done by the
writer it's rarely just sit on your
hands I have a writer who um was in a
showrunner meeting today I don't know
how it went yet um who is always out
there who's always networking who is at
every event who is on a board with the
wga who's on a board with the PGA who is
just always out there working for
himself and getting himself out there
and yes his agents at WME are carrying
part of the load but he is doing a fair
share of the work now the important
thing to remember is that your agents
and your managers they're collecting
10% getting a writer his first job is
not 10% of the work it's going to take a
lot more than that because of that
writers have to always be vigilant about
getting out there and working their
contacts and communicating with their
people and getting to know showrunners
and doing everything that they can if
not to get the job then to inspire their
reps to work even harder for
them okay so now I'm repped now what
where does the real work begin now now
the pressure is on now the real pressure
is on because ultimately you got repped
on a script you got repped on a contest
win or a fellowship placement now it's
about continuing to impress your rep
it's no longer about the one script that
will get you that one person's attention
now it's about staying front of mind for
your rep so it's continuing to generate
work not taking too much time between
scripts but making sure the scripts are
up to standards it's about continuing to
network calling into your agent's office
and saying I just met with Yad y can you
send them the script it's about you know
I have a writer who just got signed got
two months ago um and she is constantly
she's a master networker she is
constantly out there meeting with people
and calling her manager and saying I
just met with this person who wants me
to work on that idea please please pick
it up and run with it um so it's working
even harder working with a greater
sensitivity to your manager your agent
sensibilities what they will or won't
get out there it's about showing them
your hunger not not in words but in
actions um it's about managing your
communication it's about understanding
that until you've begun to work they're
working for you for free so you better
be nice about
it it's uh it's really not the time to
puff up your out your chest um you know
but really respecting the relationship
and respecting what they're doing for
you often times for free for a long
period of time while continuing to
impress them you want them to continue
to bet on you and for that you have to
hit the bullseye every time
so the writing has to be that much
stronger you have to deliver you have to
be great in meetings they have to get
calls from their friends the executive
saying April was just in here oh my God
I loved her she is so great I want to
develop something with her keep me in
mind for her next
script you have to impress you have to
impress at every
turn and you know often times most
writers by the time they get picked up
for representation have the capacity to
do that because they've interfaced with
enough writers they've met the industry
they've worked on their personal story
they want to be collaborative they want
that push and they understand that this
is a hard industry to crack but once you
do it's it's really great it's really
fun um and so they're willing to put in
the work but the work only gets more
demanding I don't know that harder is
the right work word but more more
demanding as you go along as you get an
agent as you get a manager as you meet
Executives as you impress Executives as
you build your fan base that wants to
read the next thing and the the next
thing you always have to get better you
have to get
stronger does the screenwriter find
themselves an agent or does the work
find them the agent in a perfect world
the way that we'd love to see it work is
your script comes in as a finalist for
the nickel every manager and agent in
town reaches out to you boom you have a
manager or an agent right you win the
UCLA contest very much the same scenario
Austin Film
Festival that is not always the scenario
the scenario for most writers is that
they're going to work pretty hard to
find the rep it's usually going to be
manager first because managers really
today serve as talent scouts for the big
agencies um and it's going to take a lot
of work a lot of diligence and a lot of
consistency to find that rip so for
example one of my writers who just got
signed a couple months ago had this list
of the managers and agents that she
would approach every time she would
finish a script and it was vetted and
she knew it was ready to go she had
placed top three in final draft some
years ago but nothing materialized rep
wise and so she had finished a new
script that she was really excited about
and we were sitting across from one
another and going through her list and
she said ah do I have to send a script
to this manager again I've sent him like
five scripts and he doesn't like
anything and I said yeah you send it to
everybody that's just what we do and 3
weeks later that manager became her
manager who's now sending her out on an
extreme amount of generals and
showrunner meetings um because finally
the thing came aboard that he felt okay
I knew you a writer I knew you were good
I know that you're consistent now you
wrote something great um so often times
it ends up being the writer finding the
rep rather than the rep finding the
writer um even though we'd like to think
that in a perfect world a you know rep
would come knocking on your door in
truth it's a referral business so the
best reps and the best relationships are
forged through referrals where somebody
will say hey my friend Joe just finished
this great script you should read it um
because really that's what the industry
trust we're we're highly social industry
um so if you can get those referrals
which is why you Foster relationships
those are Priceless um it's much easier
to get a rep through a referral than it
is through a contest placement unless
you're winning that contest um or
Through The Blacklist unless you get the
coveted nine rating on The Blacklist um
so really it's about working those
relationships so that those referrals
will be in place when you have that
script that that's ready to
share let's talk about inconsistency for
creatives versus the people that maybe
they're so on the nose and so precise
but maybe they've lost some of the
creative flare I happen to see a lot of
people that are inconsistent be
incredibly creative and actually have
brilliant ideas they just don't follow
up on them yeah and then on the flip
side the ones that actually do follow up
sometimes the creativity or the Flare
still needs to be flushed out so how do
you nurture both types
well you really have to look at writing
as a job rather than a
muse right it's um Larry Carusi and
Scott Alexander talk about they they
wrote um people versus OJ Simpson and
Larry Flint and and a whole bunch of
biopics and biod dramas and they talk
about this is a job and we go into work
even when we don't feel it and some days
the writing is great and some days it's
horrible but it's the work sometimes you
have to write through a lot of horrible
pages to get to some good P pages and
I'm a big believer in that um you know
sometimes you have to try something
different um you know so it's staying
agile and open to the different ways to
access
creativity uh sometimes it's rejecting
creativity and just going for
inspiration and through inspiration
getting back to creativity but you have
to accept that what works on one script
will likely not work on the next and so
you always always always have new tricks
to try in your writing new ways to
access the work new methodology to
follow new things that will inspire you
you know and if if nothing else then you
know you go and do something for fun uh
because fun be gets motivation um so
whether your fun is dancing or hiking or
jogging on the beach or whatever it is
you usually come back pumped up and
excited um that said you know creativity
is tough to always channel so a lot of
my writers rely on meditation on regular
workouts
on tracking systems to set their
expectations for what they're going to
create and when um you know a lot of
self journals a lot of goals and
targeting um so that at some point your
your system begins to understand that
you have to show up whether you feel
like it or not what are those tracking
systems that's really interesting um
there's something called self journal
the lot of my clients use that is a
planner um a task driven planner um with
short-term goals and long-term goals a
lot of writers rely on systems like
Pomodoro um that requires 25 minute
sessions um so really varies depends on
the writer um but every writer finds
their path so some writers write for
page count some writers write for our
count um you have to find what is your
comfortable space to write three pages
at a time or six pages at a time or
three hours at a time what can you meet
what can you meet consistently because
it's kind of like going to the gym first
few days are going to be really really
hard especially when you haven't been in
a little while on day 12 13 14 you're
going to hit your stride and if you keep
going then you're going to be fine um
and it's the same with writing you just
have have to keep doing it in order to
get comfortable with it um the beginning
is always going to feel Rusty and clunky
by the end you're going to be hitting
your
stride Lee you mentioned earlier some
planning and tracking software I'm
wondering in terms of uh screenwriting
programs can it really teach someone to
be a better writer
no
um you know truly writing is inspiration
writing is a
craft if you get a hammer it's not going
to teach you how to be a better
Carpenter and may make the cre creation
of carpentry easier just not going to
teach you how to be a better writer um
you know it is a craft it's a craft that
has to be practiced um sure there are
tools like dramatica to help you etc etc
and save the cat and all of those um but
you know I've seen writers take on Save
the cat and not get screenwriting to
save their lives um it's not paint by
numbers and you know if you're
colorblind painting by numbers is really
not going to work for you and that's
pretty much the equation so I think that
all of those things have their uses and
I think that they can be very
important guides um for the mechanics of
your work but you the writer are going
to have to master the craft I'm a big
believer in Malcolm gladwell's 10,000
hours um you shouldn't be shy of getting
those
um you know for most writers the first
script is not going to be the script the
second script is not going to be the
script you're going to have to really
get better at your craft and there's no
shortcutting that even if you filled out
the you know 40 beats of save the cat
perfectly that's does not mean a perfect
script
ever right it's like Malcolm gladwell's
the
outlier terms of
environment fostering genius or genius
already being in someone but environment
either hindering it or getting it out
there have you seen that where oh
certainly listen there has to be a
kernel of Genius there you can be a
technically proficient writer but if
you're not able to invest some soul in
your work if you're not able to really
get feel the way that that it sings then
it it will always feel mechanical you
know I had a girlfriend growing up who
really really wanted to be a great
pianist she never felt it so her playing
was entirely proficient but entirely
cold and the same thing happens with
screenplays there has to be some whether
we want to call a genius or anything
else Talent something innate that you're
able to invest in the work that makes it
uniquely your own or else it just
becomes a perfectly technically executed
screenplay but not a great screenplay
and I do believe that that's the
difference between good and great it's
that extra thing and certainly
environment can nurture or destroy it um
but I've seen I can tell you sadly that
I've seen Writers come to screenwriting
and really really really want to get it
but they don't and you try it every
different way I was I was speaking
recently to a friend who's a UCLA
instructor who said you know I always I
always believe that anybody can be
taught how to write and then once in a
while somebody walks in my class and
reminds me that no that's just not the
case there's some things that either you
understand them innately or you don't I
think most people that come to this come
with some innate understanding of
screenwriting with the flow of
screenwriting um with the general
structure the general rhythm of
screenwriting um but I think you
certainly want an environment to nurture
it to promote it and to help you rise to
your very
best criticism makes our best work
absolutely listen I I believe in kind
criticism so I don't believe in cruelty
for the sake of Cruelty but I don't
believe that we learn much from
compliments I think they can certainly
boost our ego and make us feel good but
the learning happens from criticism or
the learning happens from where we can
improve what we can do better that's how
we grow while you know flattery and
compliments feel great we're not going
to walk out a better writer tomorrow
because of what we learned from the
compliment
we're going to perhaps be more self
assured in what we did originally well
which is great and I'm not discounting
that but criticism is what teaches us
and challenges us to become our
best what was the internal dialogue that
you had when you decided that
screenwriting for you sitting down
writing a script maybe wasn't what you
wanted to do but you wanted to coach
people you wanted to bring out their
best for me it was really in the
development process when I realized what
a foolish child I was thinking that you
can write a script and then fast forward
six or 9 or 12 months and see it brought
to the screen and being on set while
watching your vision come to life um I
understood that I came to it from a very
naive point of view uh from a fantasy
based point of view that wasn't the
reality of what it of how movies get
made and what the writer's experiences
and I ultimately realized that that
wasn't the experience that I wasn't I
wanted to have or the experience that
would make me happy or fulfilled in my
day-to-day life and I was lucky enough
to have discovered that at a fairly
young age at the age of 23 um to say
whoa that no not for me I'm not enjoying
this this is nothing about this is
exciting or motivating for me um that
said I always loved story and I always
loved writers so from there I went to
development and really realized my heart
was with with the writer the writers
were my people um more so than the
directors that I never really got or the
actors that I dated but never really got
um so my heart was with the writers and
so I wanted to Foster talent I wanted to
support writers and it's funny because
today if I watch a tennis game and
somebody wins the person wins and goes
out and you know jumps up and down
they're so excited the person I identify
with is not the tennis player the person
I identify with is the coach that you
get like one second of um who's just so
proud and so and feel so rewarded for
what their player had done and that's
for me that's the most fulfilling
experience being able to help others and
being in a position where somebody comes
to me and says I need help I think
that's a highly privileged position to
be asked to provide help in in an area
in which I can
help have you seen people that have the
no whether it's to be a great pianist or
to be a great writer but in terms of the
daytoday actions that they're going to
undergo it's actually not what they're
suited for oh absolutely and and what
what are those what is that temperament
and what is it just it's being alone
it's being self-driven task oriented
it's not just that I know a lot of
writers and these I'll put in quotation
marks who talk about writing all the
time who talk about what they want to
write and how much they want to be a
writer and how much they want to be in a
room and how much but never make time
for the writing itself so to me those
those are the writers that will usually
bring me to the conversation of do you
really want to write because you're
talking about it all the time but you're
not actually doing it and if you are a
writer who is not
writing then what are you in terms of
this career you have to have the
discipline you have to have the desire
you have to have the drive and you have
to be willing to make the sacrifices
that most writers do that it takes in
order to become a writer and that means
waking up in the morning early if you
have a day job sorry um or writing on
the weekends or writing after hours
rather than running around partying with
your friends there's a lot of for Mo
most writers most writers are not
independently wealthy right they're not
going to be able to sit around all day
and take four hours a day to ride and
then go party and then go run around
then go travel the world so most Riders
are going to find themselves in a
situation where they have to have a day
job potentially they have a family they
have a partner they have friends they
have relationships they want to maintain
and so writing is going to demand some
level of sacrifice I had a writer that
ID worked with for a number of years who
we would meet every three or four months
and every three or four months she would
sit down and tell me the list of excuses
for why she didn't write the previous
three or four months so the job was too
hard and she had to work out because she
wasn't healthy and she wasn't sleeping
well and she had to move apartments and
she was fostering dogs and there was
always
something um and she I truly believe
that she wanted she believed she wanted
to be a writer but at the end of the day
if you're not engaging in the thing
right whether it's writing or playing
piano or any one of the things you
cannot claim the thing as your own you
have to engage in it in some consistency
and you know similarly I meet writers
who wrote a screenplay 10 years ago and
haven't touched it since but they're a
writer but you have to actively engage
in the thing if you want to be taken
seriously as an owner of the
thing Lee let's talk about writing
Partnerships sure and is it like finding
a good roommate is it nothing like that
no it's like buying a house together and
committing to living in it for the rest
of your life okay um writing
Partnerships
are mostly tragic they mostly end in
divorce um you know I do work with a
couple of Partnerships that have been
consistent Through The Years um that
have been successful but it's two
writing Partnerships that have lasted
from the dozens that I've seen break up
over the years some of which were quite
successful together um so if you choose
to participate in a writing partnership
you have to really understand what it
means to you to your body of work um
effectively the moment that you are that
you hit with a script written
partnership with another person
everything else that will be expected of
you will be expected in cooporation in
partnership with this other person
because you and this other person have
been able to create the secret sauce
that made a great script the birth a
beautiful child if you will um and so
when you consider writing Partnerships
you really want to consider what it
means for your body of work are you
willing to discard your previous body of
work or not do anything with it should
you hit in a partnership um are you will
willing to write more than one project
with that writing partner um because an
agent or manager is going to take on the
partnership not an individual writer
oftentimes they're not going to want to
get involved in the drama of a
partnership breaking up that can be very
unattractive I have a writing a TV
writing partnership that just broke up
that the agent told the two writers who
broke up either I take both of you on
individually or I take neither one of
you on individually so even broken up
the writers both had to make sure the
other impressed in order to keep the
agent for both of them or else they both
lose because the agent just didn't want
to get involved in the politics she
didn't want to have to choose um so you
really have to consider whether you and
the writing partner want to write the
same sort of material if you have the
same vision so if one wants to write
film and the other wants to write TV and
that's all you want to write that's
going to be a problem the times that you
can really vacillate in and out of a
partnership is if you're writing
together on television but you're
writing alone in film then you have a
little bit more wiggle room but in
general I find that reps want to either
rep the team or the individuals not both
um it's the same with producers sorry um
who want to work with a team who brought
them a a beautiful previous project um
you know so you really have to consider
what the partnership is what the
partners bring into the partnership so
you really want to think about how does
the the partnership balance out are we
good with the distribution of work are
we going to be good for the next 10
years because if one writer is doing the
heavy lifting and the other is is just
giving notes are you going to feel okay
about it in 5 years when your writing
partner is collecting 50% of your money
just for giving notes um are you do you
have a common vision for what it is you
want to write in 10 years in terms of
genre in terms of the space you want to
be in all of those things have to be
thought through you certainly want to
get the terms of the partnership on
paper um you know because the truth of
the matter is most most Partnerships do
go self I'm thinking of what I like to
call the two Steves wnc and job so you
look at if it was two Steve Jobs it
wouldn't have worked but because they
both had these different skill sets it
worked yeah and so two writers have
almost got to be Polar Opposites don't
you think for it to work they have to
complement one another they have to
supplement where the other is weaker
they have to bring the best out of each
other they have to push each other they
have to be able to
fight um you know certainly you don't
want two writers who do the exact same
thing together right because then is the
partnership the sum of its parts or is
it less than that um you know so you
want writers who compliment one another
one another where the other is weak
right right interesting do you think
people really know that when they first
no meet someone no um a lot of
writers that I find tend to look to
writing Partnerships because they don't
want to write alone anymore because
it's just comforting to have somebody
waiting for pages on the other side of
things um because they're finding that
that it's getting tougher and tougher
for them to push a script through so why
don't I do it with a writing partner um
I find that most writers go to
Partnerships that way without taking a
step back and
saying am I really ready to step into a
creative marriage here some of them do
most of them don't um you know I've had
Partnerships Who Sold multi-million
dollar scripts and then broke up um
because the relationship was so
difficult why at that point because the
writers can't stand each other at that
point because they hate each other
because they couldn't think less of each
other's creative talents um because it
was
never it was never a positive
relationship to start with potentially
you know I had one one relationship
where that had a feature film get
greenlit where the two writers just
could not get along one was incredibly
abusive and condescending and kept
insisting that he was doing all of the
work when the other was really doing the
brunt of the work um just didn't want to
go through that again um so I've seen WR
writing Partnerships break up with a lot
to lose and I think it's not for nothing
like I said I've also seen writing
Partnerships succeed but I think it's
where the Partnerships come together
with a point of view of doing this
together for the Long Hall as opposed to
let's try it out really thinking about
it um as a long-term relationship as
opposed to we'll test the waters and
then
consider what about choosing an agent or
manager I mean it's great to have one of
the big powerhouses want to rep you but
how do you know if that person's really
for you the same temperament the same
the truth is that you never know um you
know there's a lot of selling that
happens with when agents and manager
Court Talent um but you certainly want
to query your agent manager verbally
when you meet with them um what is it
that they do do they believe in general
meetings do they not believe in general
meetings are they going to get you your
first Staffing gig do do they not
believe in it do they want you to do
fellowships what do they want you to do
what are they going to do for you um do
they give notes do they not give notes
do they sign off on log lines do they
just want you to write blindly and
either they like it or they don't um so
you really want to ask those questions
um not in a disrespectful manner but
just to understand what this particular
rep is willing to do for you with with
managers the bigger qu the biggest
question is do you develop do you not
velop those are two different approaches
to management um do you are you for
agents are you not for agents are you
going to help me with Staffing are you
not those are things that you want to
understand so that you don't get an
agent or a manager and then six months
later go wait you're not going to help
me get my first TV job wait you don't
develop and I'm just going to keep
writing scripts and either you love them
or nothing happens to them they go back
on the Shelf so those are things that
you really want to inquire about with
the people that you're meeting with just
to understand the dynamic of the
relationship is it advisable to try to
switch agents within the same house of
representation it's rarely promoted or
allowed um you know the usually agents
will move clients as opposed to clients
will fire One agent for another so for
example I had an um a client at CIA
whose lit agent went two Talent so she
was assigned another agent um within the
agency because the agency didn't want to
lose her um but it's considered fairly
difficult to change agencies or agents
within an agency without burning some
some relationships um the one thing that
I do see happen is say you are with a
big agent in a big agency and they're
just much too busy servicing their big
clients that's when you can come in and
say listen I know you're really busy
servicing JJ Abrams is there any way
that I can be assigned a junior agent
for the day-to-day um to potentially
bring somebody else onto the team um to
help you out in just submissions getting
you out there uh be it for assignments
for Staffing anything like that um
that's when you can have Team growth as
opposed to just be changing
hands Lee what do writers need to know
about writing for
television a lot um writing for
television um it's it's a corporate job
really in a lot of ways it is a morning
toight regular in-office job granted
every office is different so you're
going to have some rooms where you're in
the room for 40 some odd weeks you're
going to have some rooms that convene
for three weeks after which writers go
off to write their own episodes um it
works differently with every show some
shows writers from staff writers will
end up on set producing their own
episode and others they won't it but it
is similar to a corporate structure in
that you rise up in the levels from year
to year um if you are writing
consistently doing a good job you're
expected to see bumps from year to year
so staff writer to story editor story
Editor to Executive story editor on and
on and on um they say that television is
significantly harder to break into but
easier to create a consistent income in
so easier to make a living in on an
ongoing basis uh film on the other hand
is easier to break into um you know but
television really is all about character
theme and World it really is about
exploring those and examining those in
an ongoing basis film tends to be more
plot driven um but things like pitching
in the room being able to present ideas
in the room being able to politic
properly within a room in order to
promote yourself all of that comes into
play in the world of Television um it's
highly competitive therefore highly
social um you really have to keep your
showrunner relationship your executive
producer relationship and your
relationship with a network if you're
working in a network environment um
fresh and
fostered um it's really a 365 day a year
job it doesn't have the freedom of film
um where you really are kind of sent off
to do your rewrites even on assignment
um you are constantly working in harmony
with others um and it's a world where
people easily lose their job get new
jobs etc etc um so it's a demanding
world it's a growing World we're seeing
you know roughly 4,100 WJ members
collect income from television per year
and I'm not talking about residuals um
it's also a high reward kind of world
because as you rise in the ranks you
will get more and more and more
financial reward um and it is a world
where you can build a living right you
can buy a house and assume that in five
years you'll unless you really mess up
in some grotesque worry you will be able
to maintain a living that said I've seen
writers mess up in grotesque ways in TV
and continue to work once you're in
you're able to sustain a career it's
very tough to break into there are two
paths that are seen as kind of the the
more sure bets to break in in a world
where nothing is certain so those paths
are the television writing programs that
are offered by the networks um as well
as a few additional organizations such
as humanitas Sundance HBO um Cape nhmc
those kind of writing programs that
Foster new Talent um that's one way to
break in another way is to go the
assistant route um so become a
showrunner assistant become a writer's
assistant even start as a PA in the room
that said there are other ways to
breaking in the web has been very
helpful we're seeing people like Issa
Ray um really make their Mark
transitioning from the web to television
of known writers to um write web series
and from that get staffed um it's highly
competitive but the majority of wga
sanctioned jobs are in television today
um and it's a growing industry what is
shrinking is the size of the room um so
as we go into more basic cable and
digital rooms we're seeing those rooms
get smaller so I have writers in network
rooms where I have 18 writers in a room
you're not going to see that on an
Amazon show on a Netflix show on a Hulu
show you're going to see significantly
smaller rooms that are very tour driven
um but certainly it is a growing
industry where everybody's looking for
great new voices let's talk about
finding the culture of that room and
respecting the culture and being able to
fit in the culture is different with
every room so you know I had this year I
had one writer in one room that opened
at 11: closed at 3: was open for 3 weeks
and was done the writers had lunch
together everybody got along it was a
bit of a Kumbaya um you know I've had
writers in rooms that it was pure
tyranny um where the showrunner ruled
the room with a heavy hand um where
there was a lot of persecution of the
writers who didn't fit in and that's
where I think it's very similar to
corporate structure you can have great
corporate environment and you can have a
poor corporate environment um but it
really is about learning your place in
that room so if you're coming in as a
staff writer learning when to pitch when
to sit back when to support when to shut
up
um what to get involved and what not to
get involved with so of course you have
lists of no NOS um you know you don't
want to step on somebody else's pitches
you don't want to write a dead pitch you
don't want to engage in office gossip
you don't want to write anything about
the room on on Twitter ever especially
if it's negative um so you have those
things that are the the kind of codes of
conduct that said every room is
different so I've seen writers get away
in some things with in some rooms where
in another room forget about it um you
know but it really is for for new
writers it is about finding your place
being able to be useful being able to
not melt into the background um and
really contribute to the room from g day
one because it's a kind of job where you
have to perform from the first day there
is no learning curve you don't have the
time to ramp
up well it sounds like also do you have
to make it work within your room with
those I mean sometimes you're going to
be there what 15 hours a day with people
absolutely um you know comedy rooms tend
to go longer
just because things are funnier at
midnight than they are at 2 o'clock in
the afternoon um but you do have to make
it work or else you'll be cut with a
first Cuts you know nobody is picked up
for a full full season for television so
usually you'll get a first contract with
a back number of weeks right so 10 weeks
with a back 10 20 weeks with a back 20
and then the show will have the right to
exercise your option to bring you back
for that extra set of 20 weeks extra set
of nine weeks whatever it is um and that
will be dependent on whether or not they
feel that you are a value um they may
decide not to exercise your option and
just let you go they may opt to not
exercise your option and replace you um
so you have to be useful at every step
of the way um you have to be productive
you have to help others and prop others
up if you want to keep that job um it's
in some rooms you get your episodes and
you just focus on that when you don't
have your episode you're done you sit
and wait for your episode assignment in
other rooms you're going to be at the
board um or you're going to be helping
out when the writer who's assigned to an
episode is at the board you're going to
board an episode you're going to break
an episode together you're going to help
research um so you really have to make
yourself indispensable to that room
what's the fine line between pleasing
the showrunner but not stepping on the
toes or threatening the other writers in
the room that's where the politicking
comes in right because you want to find
your upper level allies right whether
it's your showrunner or the coep that's
usually the number two in the room you
want to have those allies who are
rooting for you who are fostering you um
but you want to remain friendly with
everybody else um so you really have to
make sure to not be boastful um to not
be arrogant to be grateful for whatever
it is that you have whatever whatever
responsibility you are given to take
input from others at every Jun juncture
at every moment at every step of the way
um because that will continue to
ingratiate you with the other writers
that you ultimately have to rely on and
in every room there is that moment where
somebody can be thrown under the bus and
you just don't want it to be you so you
have to remain in good favor with as
many people in the room as you can okay
so let's take the situation of you are
thrown under the bus how do you keep
your character in good standing and not
let anger come through but still fairly
defend yourself or maybe there's not a
way to do that um it's a tough thing to
do and that's why you want to have
allies in Upper levels who will stand up
for you because if you're a staffy who's
thrown under the bus there's only so
much you can do for yourself um if
you're able to continue to impress your
showrunner or your number two there will
likely be somebody coming to your rescue
if there's any decency in the room and
that's why you want to maintain those
channels of communication um you know
the truth of the matter is you want to
avoid being the person thrown under the
bus to start with and that's why you
want to Foster those relationships on a
regular basis while not throwing anybody
else under the bus um because once
you're under the bus it's very very
tough to get up from under in that show
you may be able to resurrect on another
show um and it's very very much possible
on TV is an industry where you fail up
which is a great luxury um but once
you're thrown under the bus it's a
little late um so you really want to
proactively instill the relationship
ships really fortify the relationships
that will put you in a situation that if
you're thrown under the bus and fired
everybody will come in and apologize to
you and that does
happen